romantically say this as this is like
really like a meat thing is like hard to
be romantic Noah is gonna go ahead and
read some of his most romantic tweets
but there's a little bit of a twist I
want you to say it in your sweetest most
romantic voice you got it give me some
of that acting please yeah sometimes
when I'm feeling lonely I take myself
out to dinner a crowded restaurant you
ever done that you ever gone to like
sweet dream you ever gone the sweet
green and just sat at a table by
yourself and eating food it's nice it
feels good you kind of reset your
recharge you put your phone down you
focus on anyway next one this is I stole
this from there's this place called
superba on Rose I've it's closed now is
in Venice California and they had this
sign right above it and it says she's
both beautiful and terrifying at the
same time like nature itself at the end
I think about it do you remember have
fun and intimately intricate making out
can be like that's the best thing
sometimes it's good it's good no it's so
good please it's hard to take it
seriously when I'm reading it back like
at the moment I'm like oh this is how I
feel I'm so passionate and like now I'm
like yeah I felt that way don't make me
feel that way again oh love deeply break
your heart love deeper and which is one
of the morals and the boys actually you
got to tell people how you feel when you
feel it this is one of my favorite reads
of all times to the girl and the
high-waisted denim shorts dark spaghetti
strapp t-shirt and red clip in her hair
who I haven't stopped thinking about
since earlier today when I didn't even
attempt to talk to you as you walked
past me I'm still thinking about you and
it's heartbreak and the fellow Jews are
we in your monologue laugh I move that
with you it's real like I swim in so I
went to New York and I was meeting with
a magazine editors and I'm in I'm in the
car and like rolling up to the place I'm
really close to where I have to get out
of the car and I see this girl they
cross in the car
Swatt wearing like those denim denim in
the spaghetti strapp in this red clip
there and I was kind of just taken at
like how shoot she was just walking with
purpose and like she was like gorgeous
from like a block and a half away and I
was like I will I'm in a car there's you
know whatever that's cool so we pull up
to the building and I literally I like
open the door to get out of the car and
as I stand up she passes me fate and
he's like walking away from me and I'm
like and I'm like walking like six feet
behind her just like thinking myself oh
my god it's her and like yo like yeah
this is like I should say something and
I I usually do why like I'm usually the
person that's like oh I feel something
I'm gonna do it
and I didn't and so then she's just like
I like she went oh I walked into the
building and I was like heartbroken that
I didn't say anything and watch that's
gonna be your wife you're gonna find her
in a few years it's gonna be a
full-circle moment and she's gonna be
like I remember you too it was May 21st
2018 at 1:24 p.m. so it was like midday
when I saw you and yeah you can remember
what you and you probably won't wow us
all right fans are gonna go in they're
gonna tell you that they they were the
girl and be ready for your deems to be
crazy I was this is an example of what
I'm a hopeful romantic cuz I was coming
out the meeting like I'll bet you she'll
be on her way home when I come out at
the right time like it's gonna work okay
don't lie got a story don't look at a
story
don't lie get his story don't don't just
don't look any story tall look at it
maybe just once that's why it was gay
and you looked at her story that was a
performance thank you for putting me
through that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]